the U.S has once again reached its debt
limits the White House said President
Biden is willing to meet with house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy but that raising
the debt ceiling they say is a nut a
negotiation but an obligation the
treasury Department warns of dire
consequences to Everyday Americans and
Global Financial markets should the U.S
default on its debts Christina raffini
is in Washington with the latest on this
Christina good morning
good morning Jeff well we're back to the
debt ceiling again look as you mentioned
the good news is Speaker of the House
Kevin McCarthy said in a tweet he would
be willing to sit down with President
Biden take him up on his offer to try to
hammer out a deal but the clock is
ticking and America's credit rating is
on the line
if we don't meet our national debt and
renege in the first time we have a
Calamity that Calamity could become
Reality by June 5th according to the
treasury Department if lawmakers can't
get a deal together now the big debate
let me be honest with you is a
fundamental disagreement on what we
should do to cut what what do we cut
well it's not just cutting what do you
raise what taxes do people pay
House Republicans especially those who
demanded concessions to elect Kevin
McCarthy's speaker say they want
spending cuts before they'll agree to
raise the debt limit the American people
are sick of it they want some
responsibility used when it comes to
spending their hard-earned money
but the White House argues there
shouldn't be any negotiation Over
America making good on money it's
already spent we think that Congress
should deal with this in a bipartisan
fashion as they have 78 times in the
past the national debt is now around
31.4 trillion dollars default could
compromise the treasury's abilities to
pay out Social Security or Medicare and
have other negative repercussions on the
U.S economy America must have never
default
wanted to do that it never has and never
will
now in 2011 the U.S saw its credit
rating downgraded for the first time
over brinkmanship over the debt limit
now we're not there yet but the closer
we get to that June deadline it could be
deja vu all over again guys
all right Christina thank you